i do think there's only one way i can
start this interview i have to say it
father son and house of gucci
are you aware of how that has that
quickly become a thing that everyone is
saying and how wonderfully
quotable this movie already is i saw it
a lot on the internet also people
shouted at me when i'm on stage all the
time can you keep a secret
father son and house of gucci in vegas
i'll be like in the middle of a really
serious song and someone will go
father's house
i have to say that came out of a lot of
great work that i got to do with the
great actors that i felt very free on
set that that was to something jared and
i did together when he said do you want
to
tell you a secret you know they that
these things came to us and i think they
came from a a place of real spontaneity
on set where you can do as much work as
possible before and then when you get
there you throw it out and you just talk
to each other and i have to say
something she is so funny mm-hmm she's
alive i mean i i remember like sometimes
i was doing a scene with her and she
just like
said really
but it's just the way she said it
and at some point really was saying tone
it down you guys are so funny and i i
didn't expect i know she was a fantastic
actress but she's a fantastic comedian
she didn't have enough so were you
breaking in scenes sometimes oh yeah no
she was so funny so that moment was
improvised father-son has a good cheat
yeah well it was the first time and then
i and then we kept it
and yeah right yeah that's really good
i think so was it in the script we
blacked out gucci needs new blood
it's time to take out the trash
feel my family
so am i
she's a handful
the bravo the coffee cup adam your
sweater the ski chalet sweater there are
articles where can you buy the sweater
that adam driver is wearing have you
seen all that obsession no i'm not about
to or no about where you can buy it no i
i knew i knew that people saw it when it
came out i hope it's gucci yeah i have
no idea is anybody are we wearing gucci
i wore my shoes i'm i'm wearing okay yes
i mean the fashion is of course
incredible did you all get to keep
anything from set was there anything you
took on the side oh i didn't want to
take any of the being that glows
anybody else get to keep a memento or
something special from their character i
i kept a pair of gucci shoes but i
always find this where you were playing
a character for three or four months i i
start feeling oh oh this is who i am and
then you take the clothes home and then
you try to wear them in life i'm like
i'm not this person at all i don't know
what i was thinking so that would happen
with the shoes i think i'm like i'm
never going to wear these but they're
very nice you know yes
i shouldn't say that but uh but when i
wore the clothes i'm like oh i know this
is actually who i am and i was wrong i
am not maurizio okay yeah yeah it
doesn't matter even if it's like a
i don't know i can't think of another if
we were about playing plumbers i i was
sure i would feel the same way yeah i
had i i did keep something but it wasn't
from jaunty it wasn't clothing from the
set my one of my acting teachers uh
beatrice
was with me every day and staying in my
accent with me and staying in character
and she gave me a gift on set it was a
little
silver bracelet with a parrot on it
because patricia rojani
now post-prison she walks around with a
parrot on her shoulder
and she gave me that and and so for the
last scene of the movie which i won't
tell you what it is i wear it in that
scene and i brought it home with me and
i also cannot wear it because i go i'm
not patricia and
it's scary
a little scary realization yeah yeah and
i and i also i like just to echo what
adam says like it's like i really got
lost in that character and i got lost
living because you know we also shot in
italy so like whether you were on set or
you were in the world you know it all
kind of looked the same except there was
cameras and i try not to focus on where
the cameras are when i'm working so
there was a there was a real blending of
the worlds i mean you are all doing
these incredible accents being these
characters for months and months in
italy who does what
oh
[Music]
don't
miss
how long did it take or how did you get
out of those characters leave them
behind i gotta say i hadn't seen gaga
for a while and
i heard her yesterday and i was like oh
she sounds so american
because
even on the phone before we started i
only heard patricia
so it was kind of it was so weird it was
shocking to me like oh
this is her voice yeah this is even
between takes and whatever so how do you
leave those characters behind is it hard
to stop speaking in the accent is it
hard to walk away and how do you do it i
i find i never have a problem leaving it
alone okay i always want it to be over
you probably have to on some level but
is it hard to walk and because you have
no control over it and i i don't try to
think of
i know i would spiral out and try to
think of ways to change it yeah you know
go back and relive something yeah i i
also i tend to really desire to drop my
character as quickly as possible
this time i didn't
do the things i normally do like dyeing
my hair i did i did drop my accent right
away
but
i think the hardest thing for me was
psychologically to drop the character
because when you start to frame your
life and the way you see the world
around money and where things have value
like who like who matters to me who like
what person is going to provide for me
what i need in order to make this happen
that that framework of seeing the world
in that way that's not who i really am
that's who she is so
for what it's worth uh i don't know
entirely what my process is like to get
rid of the character i do know that when
i went home a lot of people in my life
told me that i had no accent but was
acting weird
uh
and so i
i think
who are you but she is weird you know
like
to me she's a weird guy she's a weird
bird i mean she doesn't really fit in
yeah and she's got this kind of strange
sexual energy where she's really trying
to uh
get what she wants all the time and um
so i i tried to drop it and i dropped it
as fast as i could but i i don't
actually don't even i don't i don't know
if she's ever fully left me gucci is a
rare animal
you must be protected
protected from home
from whoever threatens it
[Music]
i'm very struck sitting by there's a lot
of star power and talent in front of me
right now when you all came to set who
were you star struck by or really
excited to meet amongst this crew if you
haven't met before i mean al pacino is
sitting here which is incredible
luckily we i had worked with him one day
on a job before so i was uh
but it's still um intimidating to see
him because he was so uh unassuming you
know there's it's not a group of people
that
uh you know are try to make you
remind you of who they are and someone i
we never met on set uh you're kind of
smiling i'm wondering what you're
thinking no i'm just saying
sort of the sunglasses goes with the uh
interpretation of me i think
you're not you you don't you will come
on and then and
uh whatever illusion that set you well
how's this yeah yeah this seems like
that's he's putting cigarettes yeah it's
al i mean it's of course it's al of
course
we love you all thank you sponsor thank
you
just the awards buzz all of the
incredible praise the movie is getting
how does that feel to hear the accolades
coming in for all of your incredible
acting work jared you're very quiet
come on i haven't heard anything
i'm just sitting here thinking about
how pacino who
we have to say out loud is
one of the greatest actors to ever live
let's see this is going to go back on
then okay thank you
one of the greatest actors to ever be on
the screen and this is this is a person
who's
taught us all how it should be what it
can be
to teach us to reach as high as we can
to fail often and
you know a person who really changed
my life so
you know al you know
was really and cinema really yeah and
just just the diversity of creative
choices let's do it again
sometimes i think you see legendary
artists and you don't know what they're
like in real life and now you are
you're the best
i loved you all i really did you're so
great to me italian he would be red
right now
yes
[Music]
you